[Music]
go then
j'adore oh my oh my they're everywhere
that's comforting
our planet will perish
and so a week
I'm Leslie self concentrate
this time we join him
that's messed up get these on our side
[Music]
here we go
Godzilla's world you just live in it
damn right
hello
is anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival alpha-2 Godzilla
fer gotta be kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the time has come
[Music]
our world is changing the mass
extinction we feared has already begun
and we are the cause we are the
infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world and unless all the
Titans are found our planet will perish
and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
your goddamn minds I am sorry but this
is the only way
[Applause]
[Music]
long live the king
[Music]
and what's with the light show
snow intimidation display Cazares very
intimidated
we open Pandora's box and there's no
closing it now
[Music]
the king
Godzilla